hello everyone this is Eric I'm back
it is 12:20 9 a.m. it's pretty late it's
been a very long day but earlier today
it was a it was the first day of the the
champions show that an event in st.
Louis where a 10 of the top players in
the world are competing in chess960 also
known as Fischer random chess for a lot
of money and if you want to find more
information you can go to us chess
champs calm I'll leave a link in the
description it's a really fascinating
event it's a completely unique format as
far as I know compared to other other
events I mean in terms of chess960 in
terms of and the fact that there is
blitz and rapid in each day and and the
players who are competing I mean it's
it's a very impressive line up with
Kasparov top all of aronia and Nakamura
fiddler etc etc so I want to show a game
one of the most beautiful games played
today between Sam Shanklin and Maxime
Vasily Roth mvl and MVL just cross
Shanklin with black it was 19 moves long
it was a beautiful attacking game
I'm the else act upon out of the opening
and the fascinating thing about this
game I was debating whether to say this
but I think I'll say it right from the
beginning just to create some intrigue
the amazing thing was the final position
white supple full queen but whites
completely lost so well we'll see what
happens as you can see they had a
Fischer random position they actually
drew the position using the chess
Gamescom
Fischer random generator before before
the games got going so they played this
position among all the matches today and
in all of the games and there was all
this debate about like opening theory
and the players were having time to
prepare before the games this move c4
was played a lot with the idea to attack
h7 right away
in this game Shanklin started with d4
perhaps a more principled move just
controlling the center and the game
started off somewhat symmetrically after
a d5 c3 Knight g6 Bishop to sea to c6
Knight g3 black could keep the symmetry
here with a move like Bishop to c7 but
black in this position decides to castle
which is which is legal for this
position
given that the King is right next to the
rook if players want a Castle queenside
then they would have to clear off in
this case if white wants to Castle
queenside the bishop would have to move
just to demonstrate this let's say black
keeps the symmetry white plays this and
white could Castle queenside like so
except why is it not letting me do that
maybe like this there we go
okay so I guess in the chest you have to
put the King on top of the rook anyway I
don't think castling queenside was
played today because it was just so much
easier to Castle kingside in fact on
move one players could already Castle
kingside
so anyway going forward with the game
black Castle kingside
which i think is a useful move you get
the King slightly to a slightly safer
Square and you get the rook slightly
more towards the center and then from
this position things got really crazy
after Shanklin ducks move pawn h4
perhaps going for the kill and taking
advantage of the fact that if Knight
take h4 then there's Bishop take h7 so
the sneaky battery with the the Queen
and the bishop is is something to be
aware of
so after h4 mvl played a really enticing
move which I don't know if I would come
up with myself and it's the type of move
that like once you see it and once you
look into it a bit more deeply it makes
a lot of sense to play pawn f5 going for
counter play as if we know this white's
threat is to play pawn to h5 and black
really doesn't want to retreat the
Knights back to
so Paula fight was played now we should
notice that the pawn on i-5 is attacked
three times and only defended twice but
if white were to take the paw and let's
say Knight take it
five this would run into a move like
Queen h2 which is actually really
annoying for whites because now white
can castle and h4 is probably just
falling so black would have a lot of
compensation and probably usually win
back the pawn here so h5 was played and
as we see mvl counter-attacks with pawn
to f4 so now both Knights are attacked
by by pawns and it looked good for white
at first after after 9f v e6 and then
this movement I take g7 just sacking the
night knowing he's winning it back and
then pontiac g6 that looks really good
for light given I mean the pawn is on g6
this King looks somewhat exposed White
has this battery but then the problem
arose for a white after especially after
blacks next moves starting with E v
White's pieces were out of play and
blacks pieces were actually really well
placed especially this these rooks
aiming down against White's King side
and yeah as we'll see in just a few more
moves black just got overwhelming
initiative so do you take if I was
played then each six was a very nice
move making sure that this pawn is
acting as a shield for the black King
given that it just blocks the Queen and
Bishop and white doesn't really have any
way to continue attacking the black King
so white developed here with Knight be
three black wins back upon Queen Tiki
five so White's still up a pawn I'm
gonna go ahead and turn off engine
analysis because the engine gives white
a pretty big advantage in this position
plus 1.4 but I think from a practical
standpoint it's just really difficult to
play because Bach has so much pressure
against this King and it's not clear
where the King should go so let's turn
off engine analysis for those of you who
want to analyze this further I will
I didn't share the link to this study in
the in the video description so people
can analyze as much as you want so Sam
played Bishop t2 here I think with
intention of castling queenside it makes
sense to perhaps go for Queens I casting
the problem for white is that after
Knight b6 if white does Castle queenside
e to hangs and the King is still very
vulnerable this queen is very awkwardly
placed and I see four is coming so so
white is already in a bit of a
predicament after Bishop d2 Knight b6
because the White King really has no
safe place to go and then we'll see the
the position just got much much worse
for a white very quickly Queens e1 was
played which I think when satin played
queen d1 he did not see blacks blacks
next idea Knight c4 with a very very
venomous threat which is very hard to
stop and after 94 MVL goes for the kill
with a spectacular move 93 check not
quite smothered mates even though the
king is pretty much smothered on f1 but
now the F file is forcibly opening up
and White has to take the Knights Bishop
to e3 was played pawn to e3 doesn't
accomplish much pawn to e3 pawn to e3 I
file opens and this is big trouble for
White's so I tried to keep things closed
with taking on e3 and then playing
Knight f3 and then the next move for
black was was really astounding I mean
the Queen has attacked you would expect
black to move the Queen here but mvl
played a amazing of pawn take f2 just
giving away the Queen and the great
thing was that after Sam takes the Queen
black can take either rook but there is
no rush this rook is trapped on e1 also
the rook is attacked on g1 so it's a
fork and the the next move here it's
just a simple improving move bishop
to h4 the bishop coming to life from the
back rink and now if we know this the
threat of ft q 1 is just unstoppable so
and this is actually a double checkmate
threat
so if white plays some random move here
let's say Queen D 4 then double check
mates
double check no way to escape so Sam
tried g3 which didn't help at all just
allows other bishop to come in
Bishop h3 check rook g2 only legal move
Bishop take g3 and then Sam just had
enough here and threw in the towel and
resigned given that F take t1 is still
coming well I couldn't delay the
checkmates y could play a move like 9 f7
this doesn't really help at all because
white is literally losing all of the
major pieces and the next like three
moves after promoting to a Queen Queen
take e1 there bishop take g2 King take
g2 and I mean black is just up a
boatload of material so really rough
game for Sam losing in 19 moves as as
white it was a blitz game and mvl is
just a monster in blitz and then Sam
actually went on to lose next game I
think in in less than 25 moves so as dr.
back miniatura wins for for MDL so so
yeah this is very exciting some very
exciting game so so far this this event
this is only first day there's three
days more of a Fisher random chess chess
960 tomorrow there will be a new
position drawn so I'm gonna be very busy
I don't know how much time I'll have for
YouTube content like this I'm working at
the event as the journalist I'm doing
social media for the club doing
Instagram Twitter and the daily recaps
so I'm I'm gonna be quite busy with with
other responsibilities but I'll try and
find time to
to do these quick videos if there are
more interesting games feel free to
check out the video description for more
links and hopefully I'll see you guys in
the near future
take care